So the concept of fundamentalist is essentially linked to
the concept of measurement in quantitmecs
before point mechanics was developed
there it was generally a knowledge
by scientists that if you have a system that this
will the term in the state
and you perform a message on it you're gonna get
a very well that i mean outcome i
want to mechanics that's no longer the case you can have
a system that is in a perfectly well defined estate
and yet when you put from certain
measurements and it you can get run the outcomes
so in order for me to illustrate that concept i be better i
need to bring the concept of super position
superposition is it's a concept that is not in here liquid
is is is it's based on assistant displaying
several linear combination of states at
simultaneously and you can think of it
as for example a radio wave carrying
many different frequencies there's nothing
in human requirement about that
what gives the point on flavor to spread position is the fact
of measuring the system
so i will instrument with an example
imagine you have a system of faros
and you prepare the system
so that all the arrows are pointing left
and then you go and you
as the existing the question are you up or down
and us every apple so because the irish point in left can be
express company described
as linux of the position between
up and down you will get
out terms of our fifty percent up
and fifty percent when you ask the question are you open
you get that result from their system
and then you can prepare with that at
a different state of the system where have
there also pointing up and have all their
point in that and you asked the same question
and you get the same result
there are two very different systems
and you have got this information
for for for a massive now
how can you determine what the difference is the
the citizens are very different
because in the first case you have prepared the system in
a pure state many suck western you
can ask to the system that will give you a deterministic
not run them out and that question is a you left all right
is going to tell you a hundred percent there left
in the second case there is no question you crash
you can ask them give you a hundred percent that then we
stick resolve because he's a mixture
so if you ask left for right
going to be around because half of them are up
of the down if you ask apple down
same thing there's gonna is gonna be fifty percent
how did this this relate to one thing random
so you can imagine that being
similar to flip in a coin is going to be hassle tales
but is not like fifty nine coin a toll
because when you flee because
the only reason you don't know the result you're going to date
is because you don't know this
energy with which a flip that calling the angle moment in
the ambient conditions in the room
and so on for so if you knew all those
variables you could predict castle tale there
viables that are hidden today to the observer
and for a lot of years scientists thought that there was
similar variables in guantanamo extent will
reveal themselves as as randomness
and it wasn't until the
seminar work off john bell in the sixties that actually
it was demonstrated that that's not the case
and now every physicist
acknowledges that there is no hearing
but it will theory that is compatible with going to mechanics
so it is really true that when you measure a system
a nature revealed from the
doesn't matter how long i think about that is i
will respond that amazing